ينضم الينا من شمال ادلب نائب مدير الدفاع
المدنيه السوريه منير مصطفى سيد منير يعني
مع بلوغ هذا الزلزال واثاره اليوم الثالث
هل تغير شيئا في واقع الحال فيما يتعلق
بتزويدكم بمعدات جديده او تقديم المساعدات
لكم
بصراحه حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتغير الحال
بتقديم معدات جديده للخوض البيضاء والدفاع
المدني هو في صراع حقيقي مع الزمن من اجل
الوصول الى العارفين تحت الانقاب وبدانا
نفقد الامر حقيقه نحن نتجاوز ساعات العمل
ستين ساعه
المصابين تحت الانقراض ذاته عرضه الى ان
يفقدوا ارواحهم جراء عدم وصول فرق القوات
البيضاء اليهم وذلك نتيجه نقص المعدات
التي ناشدنا كل الدول ناشدنا الامم
المتحده ناشدنا الاتحاد الاوروبي نشدنا كل
الدول حول العالم ان ترسل لنا هذه المعدات
في الوقت المناسب خلال اثنين سبعين ساعه
الاولى التي هي تعتبر هي الساعات الذهبيه
في اخراج عالقين من تحت الانقاض اما عندما
يتجاوز الوقت هذه الساعات للاسف تتظاهر
الفرس الحصول او استخراج احياء من تحت
الانقاضي للاسف حتى هذه اللحظه او حتى 60
ساعه عمل متواصل استطعنا ان ننتشل 2750
مصاب جزء كبير منهم كانوا موجودين تحت
الانقاب
1540 قتيل حتى هذه اللحظه او حتى 60 ساعه
عمل 1540 قتيل استطاع الدفاع المدني ان
ينتشر جثثهم من تحت هذه الانقراض ولكن
نلاحظ وبقوه ان خلال الساعات الخمس ساعات
او ست ساعات الاخيره هناك يعني عندما نجد
عائله نجد شخص منهم ممكن ان يكون على قيد
الحياه او شخصين وباقي العائله هي بين
الاموات بينما الساعات الاولى من العمل
كنا عندما نفتح مكان او نصل الى مكان
نستطيع ان ننتشر معظم افراد العائله وهم
على قيد الحياه بدا الوقت ينقذ لم تصل
المساعدات هذا الوقت في حال لم تصل
المساعدات ما الاسوء الذي تتخوفون منه في
مناطق شمال سوريا
الحقيقه الاسوا ان نرى عداد الضحايا يرتفع
وبشده يرتفع وبكثره ان نرى عداد الضحايا
كل ساعه يرتفع باعداد كبيره هناك العشرات
بل مئات من
مدفونه تحت انقاذ منازلها هي تحتاج الى من
يصل اليها بسرعه هي تحتاج الى الى معدات
حتى تساهم بالنصل الى والله ان الشعور
يعني متطوعين البيضاء عندما يكون يسمع صوت
في مكان معين ويبدا بعمليه الحفر ويبدا
بعمليه ازاله الانقاذ حتى يصل الى هذا
المكان عندما يصل الى الشخص يعني للاسف في
الساعات الاخيره صرنا نجده قد فارق الحياه
وهذا هذا هذا يعني يزيد من التعاسه ويزيد
من من يعني يزيد من الالام على المتطوعين
وعلى الناس الموجودين الذين وضعوا كل
امالهم بهذا الفريق والله لم يدخر هذا
الفريق اي جهد من اول لحظه استنفار كامل
2800 متطوع من افراد الخوذ بيضاء هم
موجودين في المواقع المدنيين يعني ساهموا
سكان المدنيين بتقديم ما يمكن تقدير ما هو
اكثر من اربعين اليه كانت تحت تصرف افراد
الخوذ البيضاء حتى يوزعوها على باقي
المواقع ولكن الامكانيات اكبر بكثير او او
المتطلبات اكبر بكثير من هذه الامكانيات
المتطلبات لا فريق الخواذ البيضاء قادر ان
يتحمل هذه التبعات ولا حتى المدنيين في
شمال غرب سوريا قادره ان تتحمل هذه
التبعات صراحه يعني
الفرق تعمل بكامل قوتها ولكن للاسف لا زال
هناك بعض الابنيه لم نستطيع الوصول اليها
نحن نتكلم عن اكثر من 400 بناء هو مهدم
بشكل كامل نتكلم عن الف بناء هو مهدم بشكل
بشكل جزئي نحن نتحدث عن الاف الابنيه التي
تم اقلاعها من السكان بسبب انها متصدعه
بسبب انها قد تكون هي عرضه الانهيار بكل
باي هزه ارتداديه حصلت وهؤلاء السكان حتى
يعانون الامرين الان هم بيوتهم الجو جو
شراء البرد شديد لا يستطيعون العوده الى
منازلهم بسبب التشققات الدعاه الموجوده في
المنازل ولا يستطيعون ان يبقوا خارج
المنزل بسبب البرد الشديد الموجود ايضا
عملنا نحن والمنظمات العامله في الداخل
السوري الامكانات حاليا كلها محليه للاسف
كلها محليه عملنا على انشاء بعض المخيمات
لواء هؤلاء السكان واستطعنا ان نؤوي عدد
كبير منهم ولكن لا زال عدد لا باس فيه
وموجود في العراء استطعنا ان نؤذي بعض
الاشخاص في في المساجد في المدارس فتحنا
كل هذه الابواب حتى ان نؤوي هؤلاء الاشخاص
ولكن هناك عدد كبير لازال هو بحاجه الى
الى ان
يقدم له المساعده صراحه مع الزمن صراحه لا
اعرف لماذا هذا التاخير لا اعرف لماذا لا
يوجد هذه الاستجابه الحقيقيه في في ظل شرح
المعدات كيف تجري عمليات الانقاذ والبحث
وكيف يتم التنسيق بين المختلفه
في الحقيقه هناك تم تشكيل غرف عمليات لكل
موقع غرفه عمليات لكل موقع عمل يوجد في
غرفه العمليات اشخاص هم من قاده العمليات
موجودين ضمن هذه الغرف وهناك مواقع عمل
ضمن كل غرفه عمليه مثلا منطقه جنديرس تم
تشكيل غرفه عمليات خاصه في منطقه مع قائد
عمليات موجوده على الارض هناك عده اشخاص
من مدراء نقاط مدراء مراكز موجودين في
نقاط العمل اكثر من 30 او 35 نقطه حاليا
يجري العمل فيها والبحث في منطقه جنديرس
ولكن للاسف هناك نقاط اخرى تحتاج من يبحث
فيها هذه غرفه عمليات واحده يتم التواصل
فيها عن طريق اداره الفوز البيضاء يتم
التنسيق يتم يتم ارسال الجهود يتم تعبئه
المدنيين المتطوعين اكثر من الف مدني
متطوع اتى ولكن لا يوجد معدات بين ايديهم
هم الان تحت تصرف القوات البيضاء يستعينون
بهم بتقديم بعض المساعده ولكن نحاول ان
نبعدهم قدر الامكان عن المخاطر الانزلاق
الانهيار حتى نستطيع ان نتحدى الزمن حتى
نستطيع ان نسبق الزمن يعني كما قلت نحن في
سباق حقيقي مع الزمن فنحن لا ندخر اي احد
يقدم مساعده الا ان ناخذه ونعطيه على قدر
استطاعته من العمل حتى نستطيع ان نتجاوز
المساعدات الدوليه لم تاتي صراحه الشعب
السوري منذ بدايه الثوره السوريه هذا ما
غيرك يا الله ونحن نحن الان نراها باعيننا
فعلا مالنا غيرك يا الله لم تصل اي مساعده
حقيقيه انا لا اعرف لماذا الانسانيه لماذا
الانسانيه تتجزا لماذا الوضع الانساني
دائما يحسب على السيد منير من الناحيه
السياسيه وينزل عليه من الناحيه السياسيه
انا لا اعرف لماذا هذا
منير مصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني
السوري في شمال ادلب شكرا لك